l'aide massive cinq chaînes wii
et nous fournirons à l'ukraine les armes
dont elle a tant besoin
nous avons déclaré que les avions russes
et les jets privés des oligarques ne
sont plus les bienvenus dans notre ciel
ouvert nous avons demandé que la russie
soit déconnecté du système swift
nous avons interdit nous avons interdit
les outils de propagande du kremlin les
citoyens les organisations les
entreprises et les sportifs européens
ont adopté une position claire et ferme
soulignons qu'ils ne traiterons pas avec
un agresseur et ne l'accueillent ronde
pas et l'europe est prête à aller plus
loin encore
nous reconnaissons la perspective
européenne de l'ukraine respecte
notre religion l'indiquent clairement
nous saluons monsieur le président la
candidature de l'ukraine au statut de
candidat et nous travaillerons dans ce
sens nous devons
nous le ferons
[Applaudissements]
nous devons et nous voulons affronter
l'avenir ensemble monsieur le président
nous sommes à vos côtés dans votre lutte
pour la survie en ce moment sombre de
notre histoire
en retournant vers le parlement européen
vous trouverez toujours un allié un
espace pour vous adresser à l'europe et
au monde est toujours toujours un ami
ce parlement européen à une longue et
fière histoire d'être une épine dans le
pied des autocrates et dans cet esprit
je demanderai l'interdiction pour tout
représentant du kremlin d'entrer dans
les locaux du parlement européen
pourquoi parce que
[Applaudissements]
interruption la présidente
parce que les agresseurs et les
bellicistes ils n'ont pas leur place
dans la maison de la démocratie
monsieur le président mesdames et filez
vite et j'aimerais finir en vous disant
ce qu'il en est des quatre principes
importants que nous avons pour notre
avenir tout d'abord l'europe ne peut
plus continuer de dépendre du gaz du
kremlin nous devons absolument redoubler
d'efforts
afin de diversifier notre système
énergétique pour avoir une europe qui
n'est plus
dépendant des autocrates nous devons
absolument mettre notre sécurité
énergétique sur une autre base
deuxièmement l'europe ne veut plus
tendre la main aux cachets du kremlin
prétendre qu'il n'y a pas de conditions
qui accompagnent cet argent les
oligarques poutine et ceux qui sont à
ses côtés ne devrait plus être en mesure
d'utiliser leur pouvoir d'achat afin de
se cacher derrière justement cet écran
la respectabilité dans nos villes dans
nos communautés ou encore dans nos
actions ce club de sport il faut
absolument que ces personnes ne puissent
pas trouver
de non droit pour eux dans notre europe
[Applaudissements]
nous pourrons plus non plus vendre des
passeports aux amis de poutine
en les autorisant ainsi à contourner
notre sécurité non ce n'est plus
possible troisièmement les
investissements dans notre défense
doivent être à la hauteur de nos paroles
l'europe doit absolument maintenant
avoir une véritable sévérité et une
union de la défense
nous l'avons montré la semaine dernière
c'est possible et c'est souhaitable et
puisque tout c'est nécessaire
quatrièmement nous devons
y battre contre la campagne de
désinformation du kremlin et je lance un
appel aux réseaux sociaux mais également
aux autres grands groupes pour qu'ils
assument la responsabilité qui la prenne
au sérieux qu'ils comprennent que c'est
impossible d'être neutre lorsque le
temps entre le son et les pompiers
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président michel madame la
présidente fin d'al aïn monsieur le
représentant borel je vous remercie
merci bhl le garantir l'unité européenne
mais également l'engagement européen à
l'heure d'affronter la menace je sais
que chacun d'entre nous que tous les
députés de ce parlement
prendront ce message unique
ils reprendront leur compte et leur
apportant également de la
circonscription monsieur le président l
and kill merci beaucoup nous sommes
ensemble matière nous serons également
ensemble à l'avenir parce que nous
sommes du côté de l'ukrainien je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]